[Music]
Miss Julie Montagu from rural Illinois
to a country manor in England you
married the Earl of Sandwich what does
that make your title well okay
technically I married the future Earl of
Sandwich so that will make me eventually
the Countess of sandwich you were kind
of Megan Marco before Megan Merkel was
Megan Markel an American marrying into
British aristocracy getting a title tell
me what challenges you really faced I
think that what people think is they
think because England and America we
speak the same language that
everything's kind of really the same but
it's not the same and the language is
still difficult for me to even
understand for kids later and like what
do you sing with that English accent
there's so much that she's gonna have to
go through it's like life changing she's
gonna have to learn she had to learn how
to curtsy to the Queen I'm a whole bunch
of other formalities like the you know
the table setting the list goes on and
that's a year-long process for hard how
did you figure it out because we've
heard megan has been studying yeah
I'm not sure I know that we've heard
that she's been studying but I think
she's just been studying with Harry I
mean if I have anything to to go by
really my husband was the one who helped
me navigate what do you think drew Harry
to her do you think there's an appeal
about her American sensibility really I
mean okay first of all its Harry so
Harry is like you know he you can see
him in interviews he's very carefree
he's funny he doesn't really like so
many of the rules but he's respectful of
them and I think with Megan he just
found somebody who was had that American
energy that American Drive that American
optimism and living over in England now
for 20 years I still get told all the
time oh my gosh we love the Americans
because of their outlook on life and
their optimism and they're able to dream
big she has become
known as a little bit of a rule-breaker
herself and wearing pants wearing the
messiness yeah believe list yeah what is
the reaction to all of that in England
what do people think of first do you
know I think I think that everybody
knows that it's hairy and everyone's
gonna be very careful with hairy and
they are already with William because
they're Princess Diana's sons the queen
has become very modern
we love that modern queen yeah and do
people in your circles are they liking
this oh nothing because it makes them
more relatable I mean you know you want
you want the monarchy to stay everybody
does I mean it's great for tourism but
also it's the oldest living monarchy in
the world and that's still obviously
reigning the oldest reigning monarchy
and I think people don't want that to go
away but the only way it would go away
is if they weren't adapting to the times
you have so much going on for kids
managing a manor your career and you've
written this new book yeah recharge for
me
recharge was really all about recharging
my life after having four kids but it's
for anybody who's just exhausted and it
goes back to modern day living we're on
our phones we're on our laptops were
we're constantly working and never
taking breaks for ourselves I needed to
find really a way that I could slow down
to speed up so that's what the book is
all about it's about slowing down so you
can't speed up and you get way more done
if you start to take care of yourself